there's certain patterns
in Europe that still
echo today
this is the spread
of the Industrial Revolution
through the 20th century
as you can see
it emanated from the
United Kingdom and
sort of spread southeast
from there
taking a very long
time to reach Ukraine
the inner part of Russia
and much later
Balkans and the
Ottoman Empire
meaning that for much
longer than many
other places in Europe
the United Kingdom
the Benelux and
parts of western Germany
have been industrialized
what makes this
really interesting
is when we overlap
this with a literacy
map of Europe
this was literacy
in the year 1900
what immediately
stands out is
that Scandinavia
the United Kingdom
and Germany were
all extremely literate
down the line
that seems to contribute
to overall economic success
which is reflected
in the case of this
map of the
European Union
with average
disposable monthly income
Germany the
Netherlands
Belgium Norway
all of these countries
have above average
disposable income
which is super
interesting when
we come back
to the Human Development
Index map
as Germany Scandinavia
the United
Kingdom Belgium
the Netherlands
all these countries
seem to have an
above average level